I grew up I think Andy you did as well
chips was a huge TV show yes
massive TV show and one of the probably
the biggest star on it was Erik Estrada
oh but I think we have a picture of Erik
Estrada there he is
I borrowed that from Andy's dressing
room yeah he was on his way to a funeral
yeah that a baby's blanket I have to ask
you Michael you you took over the role
of ponch the the Erik Estrada role I
know what I'm working with but I tried
yeah he was also 25 in that fetus right
there here's my question for you Michael
you're you're ponch is different both of
your characters why did you have to say
ponch here area know what I was
mentioning is that you took your
character and it was a group decision
your punch is a sex addict yes that's
part of your character yeah what was the
thinking behind that well I did a little
bit of research and then what's odd
about that research is that like with it
just seems like a normal guy
seems pretty normal to me so getting out
of the bathroom 10 12 times a day yeah
yeah that's a big deal so so you
research what sex addicts are like and
you thought they're just guys this guy
but he latched on to something really
amazing which was the specificity of
their addiction right yeah like how
particular they are about some of these
guys really love yoga pants and they
love the brand names of these yoga pants
and the stitching of yoga pants and he
came up with a word what is it banana
grundle on its own out of context it
elicited a response I saw a
physiological change in your finger on
my eyes widened by my heart rate
quickened by banana grundle banana grunt
don't Nana grundle I just made it up but
doesn't it sound like a part of a yoga
pant it does it sounds like where the
seams come together is the gonna gusset
the gusset yeah yeah I don't even know
what a gusset is still known so he has
to explain it to me he
very particular about the kind of banana
grundles a certain genius you guys how
do you so our dude is that a kind of
thing that either of you notice in real
life or ladies is particular young man
some girl was walking here I think we'd
all notice in yoga pants yeah in fact
you can be with your wife in your your
head in your head you're screaming don't
look at that woman that's terrible don't
and as you're screaming in your head
don't look you're literally going like
this right in front of your family yeah
children I like I'm crossing the kids in
the backseat to keep looking you're
sweating still honey down down down very
athletic woman over there working very
hard but yeah they're they're powerful
you you shot to convince Warner Brothers
to make this movie you shot a low-budget
trailer is that correct yes what was
involved because that's unusual that it
people do that no we were desperate and
so what we did is we made this little
three-minute thing just to show everyone
what we would look like as Jon and ponch
and we're you know doing stunts on
motorcycles in Baba
but but I really found out what painting
was made of during this because we oh it
was low-budget I think I made the whole
thing for five grand the stunt man had
worn these leathers all day long a full
leather outfit in 115 degree heat and
Angeles Crest for eight nine hours doing
stunts limb and then pain you showed up
and he got in those things he put him
right on yeah it's like basically like
it almost felt like somebody handed me
like what they were wearing saran wrap
all day and you know I imagined me when
he he he jumped into those leathers yeah
and I was like this guy's got mad why
they were very like slippery yeah yeah I
guess he slid right dead slid right up
my god but I knew I was dealing with a
real like Raging Bull style actor right
a guy who go the limit yeah someone
else's sweaty leathers that's a true
Seth what we're looking for
you